foreign
active investigations Happening Now by
the Nevada State Board of Pharmacy
regarding drugs which are becoming very
popular for weight loss the 8 news now
investigators confirming this after
complaints were received now there's a
shortage of semi-glutide drugs like
ozempic and wachovi some patients are
turning to compounding pharmacies or
even shopping online but the FDA says
some of those drugs have the wrong
mixture which can be dangerous important
to note that will Gobi is approved for
type 2 diabetes and weight loss while
ozempic is only approved for type 2
diabetes you can read more about this at
8newsnow.com